what do you think about when you hear
the name detroit meaning detroit
michigan what comes to mind do you think
about wealth
what do you think about poor crime what
do you think about
did you know detroit's nickname
used to be the paris of the midwest
motown
motor city did you know in the 50s
detroit was the richest
city in the world per capita until
things happened
and we are looking at similar trends
taking place
with new york city the big apple the
central the world the capital of the
world
why is everybody or majority of the
people sitting there saying
i may be leaving new york 50
of people making over 100 000 of your
income are considering
leaving new york city so today we're
going to dissect what happened to new uh
detroit
then i'm going to show you what's going
on with new york city then i'll give you
a few mistakes new york city is making
today on why
they could potentially be the next
detroit so having sellers let's take a
look at this so
30 places in america that are getting
poor
let's see which one is getting poorer
the most this is an
article that's a month ago if you go all
the way down
top five buffalo new york milwaukee
newark cleveland look who's number one
new uh detroit change in per capita
income
minus 6300 change in media income minus
42 000
change in population minus 834 000
people have left
and change in poverty rate is 328
so we just talked about what the cities
that are getting
poorer right now let's take a look at
crime cbs news november 9 2020
three four months ago the most dangerous
cities in america ranked
okay let's go who's number 50 rochester
new york you know who's number 35
new haven connecticut who's number 29
dayton ohio
who's number 20. chattanooga tennessee
who's number 12
oakland california who's number four
baltimore maryland
who's number one detroit michigan is
number one in 2019 275 people were
murdered
detroit over look saint louis as the
nation's new most dangerous city
detroit's violent crime rate is 1965
incidents per
hundred thousand now when you see this
we gotta go a little bit deeper here's
some data for you to be thinking about
detroit's population has plunged over 63
percent
since 1950s it's down 26
since 2000 unemployment rate in 2009
cracked 27.8
unemployment rate in 2013 at 16
even though the population fell 63
municipal workforce fell
just by 40 adding to the strain on
public finances again
what does this mean this is population
leave-in
which is 63 percent but municipal
meaning
city employees only dropped 40 percent
meaning they had more government
employees in detroit
that taxpayer are paying their jobs they
kept their jobs
but people who are creating the jobs
paying the taxes
they left that is catastrophic for that
to be taking place but it tells you how
politics is killing
detroit detroit has the highest violence
you see all this it's five times higher
than national average
forty percent of the street lights don't
work 78 000 structures
and 66 000 lots are abandoned
arson accounts for a thousand to 12 000
fires per year 60
of those arson fires are deliberated or
empty
buildings now let's go even a little bit
deeper with detroit because we're about
to get into new york in a minute but
stay with me here
detroit owes 14.9 billion dollars in
debt by comparison
the total debt by all the other michigan
cities
combined at less than 12.8 billion let
me say this one more time
detroit one city in michigan oh it's
14.9
all the other cities in michigan it's a
big state
is only 12.8 billion and what they're
bringing in in motor city
is 325 operating deficit last year was
more than 325 000. uh 20 325 million
dollars they're not even paying their
long term they're just like listen we
can't even pay for it
they have no plans of paying the debt
they're just kind of saying look we're
not in a good situation we don't know
what we're going to be doing
but how do we get here how do we get
here so detroit 1701
founded by a cadillac literally the
french settler named antoine
cadillac to be exact fact city is the
name detroit
river which the word detroit and french
means straight
1760 there's a big war that lasts a long
time for
detroit eventually 1796 detroit finally
is under american control population in
1890 that's 30
24 years later it's 205 000 popular 205
000 people population 1920 1 million
from 1910 to 1950 city was a boom equal
to any gold rush
we've ever had in america fact in the
early 1900s
detroit was automotive capital of the
world henry ford founded ford motor
company in 1903 while dodge brothers and
chrysler also did business in the same
city
1950 car makers from chrysler to
cadillac studebaker to dodge had plans
in or near the city limits at 138 square
miles the city could accommodate boston
san francisco and manhattan all within
its city limits
1950 look at the population 1.8 million
from 205 000 to 1.8 million in 60 years
200 000 out of that 1.8 million worked
in manufacturing which is about 1 in 10.
1959 barry gordy launches motown records
who are the big stars he gets
michael jackson jackson 5. stevie wonder
the temptations the supremes
diana ross marvin i'm talking like goats
is what they get
1960 detroit is the richest city per
capita
in america according to the u.s census
bureau which becomes the richest city
in the world is what we're talking about
right what else did they do their stoves
ships cigars pharmaceuticals beer rail
cars were also produced
during this time 2013 population
from 1.8 million it goes to what 714
thousand
fewer than twenty thousand people of the
seven hundred and fourteen thousand
work in manufacturing one in fifty
remember what it was one in ten two
hundred thousand it goes from two
hundred thousand
to twenty thousand that's ninety percent
drop off
the population control detroit has
fallen back a hundred years
obviously we can go into this the exodus
on what's happened why the decline
racial riots in 1967 engulfed the city
but the most destructive one of court in
1967 a police confrontation
sparked a five-day riot that left 43
dead 467 injured 7 200 arrests
and more than 2 000 buildings destroyed
now crime 7 out of 10 crimes are
unsolved
you know what this reminds me of is what
happened in new york city
during covet the riots that was taking
place you kind of seen some of the
similarities
watch this lost tax revenue when
population declined
lack of industry diversification
globalization of car industry
and then obviously a bunch of different
things that happened there
white fight 1960 detroit population was
1.6 million
blacks were 29 whites were 70 percent
today's black comprised
84 of the population in detroit let me
read this one more time blacks were 29
70 it was good to go today's 84
whites is 8 it was more uh
what do you call it balance now it's
more lopsided
on what's taking place and the poor
taking the biggest hit today
in detroit due to certain policies that
the city came out with
so if you look at the other plans now
there are just two big factories left in
detroit chrysler
and gm the number of vacant housing
units doubled in the past decade to
nearly 80 000.
i can go on and on showing let me just
give you some interesting data here look
at this one here
a home costs less than a car in detroit
let me say that one more time
you buy a home in detroit it's cheaper
than buying a brand new car okay in
detroit
media listing twenty one thousand
dollars comparable to a car twenty one
thousand dollars chevy malibu
housing price five point two percent
median household income twenty nine
thousand dollars unemployment nine point
two percent
how bad is it when it comes when you
call 9-1-1 you ready 58 minutes
you call 9-1-1 58 minutes before cop
shows up
that means you call 9-1-1 you say i'm
about to rob a bank
you go rob the bank you leave the cop
still hasn't shown up
and you ran away with your money that's
how bad it is right now
in detroit 8.7 times a crime by police
21 minutes approximate time it takes to
respond to first calls fires only 35 000
of it
you get the idea of what's going on here
with the stats and top 10 celebrities
that born out of detroit tim allen sonny
bono
jerry bruckheimer bruce campbell alice
cooper eminem madonna tom selleck jeff
daniels
francisco i mean detroit was detroit
when you think about this place i'm
going to put the links below for you to
be thinking about it
but a bigger part of what happened with
detroit is taking place today with new
york
this article here every one of these i'm
reading i'm going to put below for you
to read
this may be a good one for you to read
is the following imagine a city
where all the major economic planks of
the status or progressive platforms have
been enacted
a living wage ordinance far above the
federal minimum wage for all public
employees everybody wants you know the
politicians right now saying let's do 15
minimum wage a school system that spends
significantly more per person
than national average a powerful school
employee union that militantly
defends exceptional pay benefits to job
security it has one for its members
other government employee unions that do
the same for their members a tax system
that aggressively
redistributes income from businesses and
the wealthy to the poor
and to government bureaucrats do you
notice that happening anywhere else
maybe a great city called
i don't know new york city now let's
look at some of the stats with new york
city here's wall street journal
okay wall street journal comes out with
an article the old new york
won't come back this is just a week ago
okay
look what it says here here are some
numbers from the partnership
from new york city business group the
city has lost 500 000 private sector
jobs since march 2020 coveted
tens of thousand small businesses 5 000
restaurants have closed
less than 15 percent of office workers
are back in the workforce
they left a year ago let me say this one
more time less than 15
are back it should say something
different it should say 85
are not back so that means that there's
a thousand employees 850 employees
are not back they're still at home
they're not working
then you continue tourism and
approximately 70 billion dollar industry
won't be back until the years back when
judith miller had a good piece in city
journal on how broadway's older houses
can't be
retrofitted for social distancing and
still make a profit no one is sure
theater goers will rush back theaters
will be reborn man will always have
shows and stories but as
what whatever comes hybrid productions
etc so you read this part then you come
here look what this one says this is the
scary one
300 000 residents of high income
neighborhoods
have fled change of address forms with
the u.s postal service you see
new york cannot hide this data because
it's u.s postal service saying
300 000 residents have changed
their address new york city maybe you're
doing something wrong you know where
they are going to
to lower income tax no income tax states
those that have a friendlier attitude
towards money making
and that presumably aren't going hard
left florida has gotten so cheeky
that this month its chief financial
officer who's a valuetainer sent
a letter inviting the new york stock
exchange to relocate to miami well let's
see what else this is going to tell us
here
this is from nypd this is not me this is
nypd two months ago
ready at the same time the new york pd
in 2020 confronted a
a plus 97 increase in shooting incidents
this is during covet where people are
apparently staying home
97 shooting goes up 44
increase in number of murders amid the
challenges of an ongoing international
health pandemic
that has strained city residents and
that the police so warned to
ensure public safety for everyone
burglaries increased by 42 percent
car theft increased by 67 percent
through it all
nypd has worked to mitigate violence as
reflected in a 29
increase in an annual gun arrest for
2020 versus 2019
including 2057 gun rights in the last
four months
i mean this is nypd this is not any
other person that's saying this
and then if you look at this here the
top 15
most expensive cities in america to live
in
go to number one what do you think is
number one okay
manhattan okay oh
manhattan medium home prices two million
forty five thousand dollars let me say
that one more time
medium home prices two billion forty
five thousand dollars
median monthly rent fifty one hundred
thousand
fifty one hundred dollars okay then you
go to number three at number two san
francisco most expensive then it's
honolulu who is number four
brooklyn number five washington et
cetera et cetera is number ten
ready number ten queens new york three
out of the ten
most expensive cities in america to live
in is in new york
and if we continue and look at this you
see articles like this this is just four
months ago if the wealthiest new yorkers
flee the city
they could take more than 133 billion
dollars with them
a report from bloomberg found that the
top one percent of new yorkers had a
combine of 133 billion dollars
in income in 2018 that paid you ready
all these rich people
all these evil rich people they paid 42
and a half
percent of the city's total income
including
aoc salary just so you know was paid by
all these
rich greedy people that means point four
six percent of the city's population
accounted for a whopping 4.9 billion
dollars in tax revenues
obviously those wealthy new yorkers
leaving could be a major blow to the
city's economy
and the number of ultra royalty city
residents may have already shrunk
due to pandemic i can go into more data
here to give you but
you know estimated 300 billion dollars
of wealth has
left and even before covid
2 600 people a week we're leaving new
york this is not a new thing
they let everybody they were losing 360
at 376
a day la was number two at 260. florida
receives it
georgia's receiving it houston's
receiving it austin's receiving it
phoenix is receiving it dallas is
receiving it illinois is losing it
that's that great city of new york
leaving new york high earners and
finance and tech explain why they left
the world's greatest city
and this explains all the different
stats on what they left different
stories i left for taxes
i left for freedom i just kind of want
to be left alone etc etc etc
on what new york city is going through
so what does all this stuff have to do
with anything here's what it has to do
um
detroit creates an incredible economy
ridiculous jobs 200 000 manufacturers
rich people want to go on vacation they
go to detroit oh we're going to go to
detroit
most beautiful homes incredible income
being made
crushing it helping out the country
creating economy
innovation then politicians show up
you're too rich
they're making way too much money this
is not fair and if you're like what do
you mean this is not fair
they should pay you more you think they
should pay me more they should pay you
more
maybe they should pay you more no they
should pay you more you go to
you should pay me more now they divide
the employee with the employer okay now
there's fight
politicians are winnings oh we got
division this is good now they come to
me
you need me politician i want to get it
done for you because you need me
and i'm going to fight for you because
it's all about you i'm the politician i
am here for you
oh thank you so much thank you so much
the boss says oh
man one employee 50 employees a thousand
employees
10 000 employees 20 000 employees we're
sorry maybe you're right we're bad
people
guess what we're leaving detroit good
luck finding a job
but but but no no no no no no i didn't
mean
leave i just been like maybe pay me a
little bit more no no it's okay no no
we're bad we're bad
you go ahead and figure out a way to
work for somebody else okay
maybe i'll go to the next car company
and i'll [ __ ] at them and then the
other one leaves
and then the other one leaves and you go
from 200 000 manufacturing jobs
to 20 000 manufacturing jobs and the
same trend you are sitting
in a beautiful city called new york city
one of my favorite cities
in the world is new york city i enjoy
the food
i enjoy the culture i enjoy the melting
pot i enjoy the accent i enjoy the
swagger i enjoy the fire i enjoy the
competition
i enjoy the shopping i enjoy everything
about new york except for the policies
it's the policies that are destroying
new york because the policies
of an aoc is sitting up against the jeff
bezos and saying all you care about is
rich people
you want to bring 25 000 jobs in new
york city because you
want to raise rent in new york city by
bringing 25 000 jobs in new york city
with an average salary 150 000
a year no we're not going to do that
jeff bezos cannot come
we're not giving them no tax benefits
and jeff says okay cool
no problem but we will leave
they left amazon becomes nearly a two
trillion dollar company it's a very big
company today
and new york could have benefit from it
but aoc didn't like that
because it's too high of a salary to
bring to new york city god forbid those
rents are raised all of a sudden
the 50 100 rent that's going to be
raised as if it's not high already
so you know what happens when you're
like that here's what happens when
you're like that
when you're married to somebody or
you're dating someone and
things are good with you and her or
things are good with you and him
everything's good then you go home your
mother or your in-laws or your friends
or somebody says he should spend more
money on you
why doesn't he buy you better stuff why
are you wearing these clothes
you should wear nicer clothes why don't
you have the latest shoes
i hear his rich shouldn't he buy you a
nicer car shouldn't end his life
well well no but he's nice he's good no
he should spend more money on you
then the girl comes home well babe um
i think i deserve this and the husband's
like i'm sorry what are you talking
about
well i think i deserve this babe i'm so
confused like we were just good like the
last week
yeah but i don't think you're taking
care of me and guys confused
where are we going with this or vice
versa you know guy goes to work and i go
sir
if i was your girl i would do this for
you i would do that for you i would do
this for you
okay then you come home i said babe you
don't do this for me you don't do
nothing for me
what are you talking about what are you
gonna do for you that
message that voice that's the politician
once it comes into marriage
it divides and eventually there's a
divorce and eventually the other person
that leaves is going to say
you know he wasn't as bad as i thought
he was he took care of me
gave me a nice place was respectful to
me was a great father
or she was actually good to me she was a
good wife she did this
she was also worker she was also a
provider she was playful what the hell
was i thinking
new york city if you're listening to
this agree disagree
fine go do your own research and the
next time you think about voting for
your politicians
do not let politicians that have access
to more wealth than ever before in new
york
divide you against job creators because
it's the job creators
and the innovators that made it possible
for new york city
to become the financial capital of the
world and hopefully
the populace of new york city who are
the employees
working maybe for the employer doesn't
all of a sudden
turn against the employer and force them
out of your state
because they will gladly come to florida
go to texas
go to tennessee and move all those jobs
that they have today
in new york having said that i want to
hear your thoughts comment below but i
got another video for you to watch
it has to do with why 15 000
apartments in new york are empty today
if you haven't watched this video
click here to watch it take care
everybody bye
you